حكومة بنيامين نتنياهو الحالية
أه هي الحكومة الأكثر يمينية
شوفينية وعنصرية بشكل علني
في تاريخ إسرائيل وتوجيهاتها
السياسية تقول أن
الشعب اليهودي له حق حصري في
كل أرض إسرائيل هذه الحكومة
تدعي أن اليهود فقط هم من لهم الحق في
قاعة الغرب BL أه بنك وأن
الفلسطينيين أه على نفس المنوال
ليس لهم حقوق سياسية هذا
موقف متطرف جدا أه لكن لا
يفاجئني لأنه في
2008 أه الكسيت أصدر
قانون الدولة القومية وقال قانون الدولة القومية
أن اليهود لديهم حق فريد في
تقرير المصير في أرض إسرائيل
وهذا يعني أن المواطنين الفلسطينيين في
دولة إسرائيل الذين يشكلون
خمس السكان هم مواطنون من الدرجة الثانية
فقط اليهود لديهم حقوق معينة
وغير اليهود ليس لديهم  هذه الحقوق لذا فإن
إسرائيل بسبب هذا القانون هي
العضو الوحيد في الأمم المتحدة الذي أعرفه
رسميًا أنه عنصري